instead of doing look at this all three
of these integrals I can say from my
graph because this is actually how I'm
making my argument right I can say from
the graph and obviously you need your
graph to be decent enough to provide
part of your visual argument here from
the graph using symmetry I'm going to
say this exact statement over here a 2
equals a 1 plus a 3 so I can use this
enormous shortcut to then say therefore
the total area is going to be equal to
and I'm just going to bring this working
out from over here right tell you the
area is 2 lots of a 2 so I've just got a
single integral that I need to evaluate
and then I will be good to go so let's
let's do that right here's a 2 up here
so let's use this guy copy that actually
I only need this part over here and I'm
gonna say this is equal to 2 lots of a 2
which is this integral in here now it's
still not easy but I can definitely work
this out and it's gonna be much simpler
than working out the entire thing with
all three integrals so 2 lot of let's
start integrating what's the function
but if I differentiate it it gives me
sign thank you carefully there's some
function you differentiate some function
and it gives you sign what function is
it now you know it's related to the
other trig function that's here if you
differentiate cos do you get sine the
answer is no you get negative sine so
therefore what I really want is the
opposite of that I want so let's go back
to that mode I want not the derivative
because I want the derivative of
negative cause that'll give me sign ok
so therefore negative cos is the
primitive function of Sonne got that
okay now in the same way when I think
about minus cos what's the function that
if I differentiate it gives me minus cos
well it's gonna be minus sine
like so so there is my primitive
function and I'm about to evaluate that
from PI on 4 to 5 PI on 4 ok I see
there's a minus sign twice so I'm going
to pull that out as a factor negative 2
is what I get a result and then I've got
cos x plus sine X from PI on 4 to 5 PI
on 4 ok now in fact I'm going to be a
bit funny and I'm going to rearrange
these I'm gonna because you can add
things in any order that you like I'm
gonna put the sine X first and the cos x
second you'll see why I did that a bit
later on now I'm ready to evaluate this
thing so minus 2 hangs out the front big
set of brackets here will value 8 the
top boundary and then the bottom once so
sine of 5 PI on 4 plus cos of 5.4
there's my top boundary and then I'm
going to subtract sine of PI + 4 + cos
of Pi on 4 okay now at this point you
can reach for your calculator to help
you with some of this it will be tricky
because there's SERDES involved it's
obviously much better if you actually
know your exact values and can do this
you know in your head or with the aid of
some triangles and that kind of thing
now I happen to know these values pretty
well because I've been dealing with this
trig functions for a long time so I'm
going to say sine of 5 PI + 4 that's
actually negative 1 on root 2 I'm gonna
leave this big bracket here and cause of
5 PI on 4 is also negative 1 on root 2
now you might have wondered how did I
know so quickly that those two values
would be the same well think for a
second PI on 4 and 5 PI over four which
appears our boundaries here when they
get those values from again like Y is 5
PI over 4 important to me or Y is PI on
4 important to me and the answer is
they're not random points the points of
intersection their points where the two
graphs sine and cosine they coincide
with each other their function values
are the same so if I've worked out sine
of 5 PI + 4 which is down here then
cause of 5 PI over 4 is going to be this
same value the blue and the green graphs
irvil lab and the same trick is true the
same thing is true
when I'm working outside of pound four
so this is going to be positive 102 and
cause is also going to be positive one
on route 2 okay
let's tidy this mess up so what have I
got here - sign out the front that - is
in there and what have I got here this
is negative 2 on route 2 - well - on
route 2 again this seems like a good
spot to cancel out this negative so I'm
going to put a 2 out the front that
leaves me with 2 1 root 2 + 2 on root 2
that's a lot of two's what do I got here
- lots of 4 on root 2 so I've got 8 on
root 2 and I don't forget root 2 is
actually a factor of the top there right
because 8 is just 4 times root 2 times
root 2 this guy here is 2 right so I can
just say well if I got a root 2 on the
bottom there I'm gonna cancel out one of
the root twos on the top and the bottom
and this gives me my area for root 2 so
I'm done I'm gonna conclude the area the
total area is 4 root 2 units squared
that was a lot of work for such a simple
answer but we got there so Wow
a lot of work was required there because
these are functions which are they're
harder to deal with than just straight
polynomials so just like before and this
is a question which will frequently
either have more information given to
you like maybe they'll provide those
intercepts for you so you don't have to
do that legwork or working out the
intercepts will be a whole other part of
the question and so you know you get
marks for that separately a lot of marks
should be given to this depending on
where in the paper that it's found and
how much help you get given okay so
that's how you work out the answer get
yourself a good sketch make sure it's
detailed enough that you can draw all
over it identify your integrals which
you can see we did here and please
notice that when you get your integrals
don't just go straight away to the
calculus look back at you
graph-like we did and see if there's any
way that you can simplify those
integrals together we simplified
dramatically we went from three
integrals separately to just having a
single integral which even the single
integral was a lot of work right can you
imagine
tripling that work and then of course be
careful when you go ahead and integrate
combine everything and conclude
carefully now just as a note to finish I
did say why imagine how complicated
would be if you had to integrate all
three of them together if you didn't for
example notice that you could do this
cool thing with this symmetry of the
graphs well let me show you what happens
when you do this is what you're working
is going to look like if you go ahead
and try and do all three integrals at
once you can see what I've got here is a
1 plus a 2 plus a 3 and I'm just going
to walk you through all of the working
here what I've done to simplify it
because there's some interesting stuff
to notice along the way so the first
thing is what I've got is from a 1 to a
3 I've just written them in exactly the
same way from the first line to the
second line no change but I have changed
a 2 I have taken out a factor of
negative 1 from here you can see I've
popped it out the front there so that I
have cos X minus sine X on the inside of
the brackets and I don't know why I did
this but there's some DX is missing so
let's fix that up I think they must have
got deleted when I copied some stuff so
I'm integrating everything with respect
to X now I wonder if you noticed why I
bothered to take away that factor or
factorize that negative 1 out why is
that useful well I want you to look
carefully at what I'm now integrating
right what I'm integrating in the first
instance is cos x minus sine X in the
last instances also cos X minus sine X
don't forget a 1 and a 3 they're the
same you know top function takeaway
bottom function but now that I've taken
at this factor of minus 1 look what I've
got on the inside its cos X minus sine X
so I'm integrating the same thing all
three times it's just easier for my
brain it's a little one less thing to
have to think about one less set of
negatives to get wrong so once you
integrate you get this next line here
which you can see I've broken into
the red the blue and the green sections
so that you can follow my next line okay
here is me evaluating the red integral
top and bottom here's me evaluating the
blue integral top and bottom and then
lastly the green one I couldn't even fit
it all on one line and then what you'll
notice is on this line here I further
divided things up because I noticed that
a lot of the terms because there's so
many overlapping integrals that have the
same or have related boundaries upper
and lower boundaries you can see for
example this guy here which I've
underlined in purple this is the top
boundary of the red integral which
matches the bottom boundary of the blue
integral so you can see those two are
going to be like terms before I even do
any simplification there's a side plan
for plus a closed point for exactly the
same thing happens here this is the top
boundary the upper boundary of the blue
integral which matches the lower
boundary of the green integral so they
match up now
there's two terms left over which don't
seem to match up but we'll come back to
them in a second so all I'm going to do
is I'm going to say okay purple there's
a negative and a negative for the other
purple so therefore you've got excuse me
- lots of sine PI and four plus cos plan
4 and then when you have a look at the
other one that's underlined in orange
you've got - this term here this
expression and then you've got - again
the same expression so you're
subtracting it twice so you'll get minus
two lots of them which is what you can
see on this line here so - lots of the
purple one take away - lots of the
orange one now I've written those on
remember I mentioned that these are
these terms over here they don't match
up to anything so I've written them in
black over here on the end but then if
you look closely something sneaky has
happened over here on the right hand
side of the lion I've done a
substitution what have I done well sine
of zero and cos of 0 these two functions
sine and cosine like we saw right at the
beginning when we sketched these are
periodic functions they repeat every 360
degrees every two pi radians so
therefore sine of zero is the same as
sine of 2pi and cos of 0 is
for the same as COS of 2pi why would I
bother writing it as two pints at a zero
like isn't zero simpler and the answer
is well now that I've got two pies here
and here they match up with this other
term over here so there is some
cancelling that happens this minus and
this plus are going to give me zero
now all I've done for the rest of it is
I have simplified out and I've got this
term in here I've evaluated I should say
sign up on four is this which you should
recognize from when we worked it out
earlier and then you go ahead and you
get the same answer for root two
so the thing that I wanted to point out
to you is if you look closely at it's
highlighted in green here and if you
look closely at this line I wonder if
you recognize where this has come from -
lots of one - lots of the other this is
exactly what we were evaluating when we
were doing the question in the first
instance see that right there - lots of
this guy okay so in other words
unsurprisingly we've arrived at the same
answer but I had to deal with far less
calculus when I was doing it the first
way because I had done the simplifying
right at the you know at the outset
rather than here where you end up
simplifying but only after you have to
wade through some really funny territory
to get there so I hope that helps these
questions you have to be careful and
methodical because a single error early
on we muck you up later on the upside if
you do make an error early on and you're
in some trouble and if you do everything
else correctly you will get marks still
but you can see this is designed this
question to simplify out if you do it
properly so take great care and make
sure you draw a really good sketch
that's a decent size so that you can get
all the right information out of it